Eric you went up you know you don't have
to plug in anything you have a movie
coming out or a couple TV shows have you
seen the toy box the show that I'm doing
on ABC when does this air when's this
gonna be on tomorrow morning oh so the
toy box is on Friday nights on ABC
that's and that's an example of how I've
recently had to realize that I'm
competing against my own character that
I play on TV cuz I'm hosting the show as
myself and the reason I'm hosting the
show the reason I even said yes to doing
it was because it was an opportunity for
me to sort of be my dry you know sense
of humor with people but people watch
the show and be like I like your
accessories as an actor but not as a
host and it's because they don't know my
personality yeah but you're so [ __ ]
funny as a person I don't really rarely
I know that you're killing it on that
channel but I only know you as a
naturally intrinsically funny guy legit
that's a honestly a big big compliment
from for me from you I really do mean
that yeah because I've always felt like
there's like I went to a Funny or Die
party after Modern Family was on and I
did feel like because I'm on in like a
network television show and I'm on that
and it's you know like gets good ratings
and wins awards that somehow I'm not in
the cool comedy club yeah I promise you
this we all want to be where you're at I
told her when I booked this pilot I just
said we might get invited to the party
because I've been to the party right
they get the club right right you're in
the club and let me tell you something
right now there is a difference you're
at a level that's completely different
untouchable untouchable but but I did
feel like I felt like the senior in like
if I was made if I and it was again on
me because most people in the your world
don't know me as a stand-up because I
wasn't or as an improviser because you
know how many people saw me improvise
for 12 years you know so I oh I felt
like that the comedy people don't look
at me
is a comedy guy they just look at me as
a guy that got lucky and is now on a
network like let me ask you this Jordan
Peele do you know him
yeah do you know him before you did
Modern Family of course yeah he's
legitimate yeah 100 per second yes you
knew him
hilarious Mike yeah yeah I mean there's
a list of people that are killing it
right now that already know that what
you can do and who you were and you
didn't need modern family to get have
them have that opinion of you Yeah right
so shut the [ __ ] up well no but you know
what I mean about the comment no I mean
I oh I've you know I've always hated
them let me say this I've been doing
stand-up for 20 years I've never been in
the Montreal Comedy Festival really yeah
and it's like at some point you just
have to go I'm not but it's fine yeah
but it's [ __ ] fine
it's fine but you're so you're an
improviser mm-hmm so let me tell you the
main the main thing real quick and then
I'll let you guys go sorry I'm talking
now no so here's something that I've
noticed about comedy is it used to be
when I was in Chicago and starting off
there at the ImprovOlympic and I would
talk to guys that were had been
improvising for a long time you would go
out onto the street and the climate at
IO is that that's just bits galore and
you just you're standing outside smoking
a cigarette drinking water doing
whatever it is in its bit bit bit bit
bit and everyone says yes yes yes yes
yes and you just do the bit and you have
no idea what's gonna come from that bit
usually nothing sometimes something now
what I feel like is is you'll be around
like let's say a couple I oh guys like
guys like me and perform on beer shark
mice and those those guys that will just
jump in and do bits you'll be around
doing bits and then add a little with a
cool guy comedy club in and the cool guy
comedy is sitting back and thinking like
well I'm gonna judge the bit first yeah
and I'm gonna decide whether I think the
bits funny yeah and then I'm gonna jump
into the bed yeah and I'm gonna kill the
bed
yes where the whole spirit of improv and
what the beauty of IO is is bits just
are that they're bits and you say yes to
them yes with no judgement yeah that's
what I feel like to me the difference is
is is there's judgement where they're
didn't used to be
yeah but also those people that judge
the horse they can't pay right prime
real estate
there's no farts going on over there I
like yeah we can put a poquito mas in my
baby you would never betray me in that
way I would never I know you William so
and Norwood vertical oh I like that she
said maybe you've said this before on
the podcast that you have a shallow very
shallow vision which is good for you
halfway no I don't hit the wall I go
halfway though anyway
[Music]